i'm gonna get destroyed by all these all
these watch geeks
hey guys henry golding here and i'm
gonna be going through my personal watch
collection i've chosen a lot of my
pieces because of the love of the design
and the love of in some cases how rare
they are or how difficult they can be to
get but at the same time like i said
like i love wearing them the designer's
impetus for creating such something so
beautiful is to be seen on a wrist
my first watch was when i could afford
one this cartier pasha which i just fell
completely in love with from the blue
robichon to the carved out details on
the face i was sort of drawn to it it
was when i finished this big travel show
pretty much my entire wage for three
months of working and i
always i was kind of just like
it felt so right at the time but
thinking back i was like wow you're an
idiot i wouldn't say that i'm a huge
huge collector but i know what i love
and i'm passionate about the ones that i
pick because they mean so much to me it
was one of those ones that looked
elegant but also had this sort of
sportiness to it would you say this is
your favorite watch
you're gonna hurt its feelings but no
but i love it dearly i love it dearly
so this is the watch that i wear the
most pretty much
never comes off my wrist to whole foods
wherever i'm going to like
anywhere usually i'm wearing this is the
patek 5711
steel case discontinued as of this year
and even if you could find them the
waiting list is
five to ten years which is kind of crazy
you have to have patek philly actually
accept you as a buyer especially now
that they don't sell them anymore the
steel bracelets are worth more than say
like the rose gold or the precious
metals it's something that i would never
sell just because i love it so much but
yeah they they they go for a pretty
penny now gerald genter the designer he
did the royal oak as well as the
nautilus it's weird if you're a watch
guy and you see the nautilus on
somebody's wrist you're just like
holy crap that guy's either got taste or
he's an extremely lucky man and have
spent a ridiculous amount of money i'm
not sure which category i fall into
[Music]
the omega sea master devil this is the
watch that i wore on my first movie so
this was something that nick young's
father gave to him and we don't see sort
of in in the movies so it almost
represents his presence
for him an heirloom that's been passed
down to him so it means a tremendous
amount something like that really
grounds your character and and gives you
a time and a place it's a manual wind
instead of automatic where it has sort
of a pendulum creating sort of energy
for the watch to consume it through the
day this has a spring coil spring so you
wind it to wind the spring and then
slowly through the day it releases
giving you the the movement it's sort of
breathing air and oxygen into this
inanimate object and bringing it alive
i'm probably totally wrong but but
that's what i believe is true
this is a tudor black bay this watch
means a tremendous amount to me this was
when i was still doing sort of travel
shows and running through the jungles
and and going into sort of
devastation in around southeast asia and
this was the replacement to the the
seiko that i mentioned earlier so this
was the upgrade that my wife bought me
for my wedding day she wanted to get me
a watch that i could wear throughout
that that entire period the backstory
with tudor is that they used to make the
cases for rolex they have that build
quality at a definitely much more of a
affordable sort of price range but for
this
on a nato strap is unbeatable i
literally trek through jungles up
mountains go diving and it stays with me
pretty much all the time if you're
looking for a watch that's gonna last a
tremendously long time this is
definitely one of the best
so this is your classic classic cartier
tank design's been around for for so so
long
one of the most timeless
timeless pieces i think i have my
collection a leather band with a small
dainty
gold watch is is one of my favorite
things and cartier especially have just
the intricacies of detail with blue
rubbish on and the sort of faintly blue
dials very small details you can pick up
on
in the light
and i like that about watches you notice
all the details as you go in closer the
tank is an absolute classic and i think
deserves to be in every man's um
collection because
they're not ridiculously expensive again
but you get so much wear out of them
this goes with
what i'm wearing today it's one of those
like really classic things or you could
put it on with a beautiful tom ford suit
with a tuxedo and it wouldn't go a miss
it's like a superpower with some of
these watches it's like it will mold in
with
anything you throw it out
i don't even know what this is called
but i'm reading it right now cassio f84w
one of the cheapest watches in my
collection but one of the watches i
actually wear a tremendous amount i
bought it in tokyo whilst i was filming
snake eyes for 800 yen which is about
eight dollars the draw really was the
seamlessness between the body and the
strap and how kind of elegant weirdly
elegant it looks it's something that i
throw on i don't have to worry about
winding or
having it run out of energy because it's
it's battery run if i'm like in a rush
sometimes i'll just grab this and know
that it'll always keep the right time
which at the moment is not on the right
time so
it's it's not 8 p.m i think it's in on
uk time actually i wore it in the uk
recently there's a chap a mater d who's
uh used to be at the tower tower bar
hotel but he was given a watch by bill
murray because he didn't have a watch
and it was one of those
it was like a timex or something that he
could like easily replace but it meant
so much
receiving it from a guy like that the
gift of sharing means so much more to
someone else than eight bucks you know
what i mean so uh so there'll be a great
story behind it at some point but i
gotta find the right person
the rolex gmt master ii the 2019
so it has a jubilee band which i
thoroughly love and that was one of the
main reasons why i got it because just
because of the band is so beautiful the
fact that they sort of switched over to
the ceramic sort of bezels i think all
steel bracelets and and steel sports
versions of any luxury watch that are
extremely hard to get usually there's
like either a waiting list or
you have to pay a little bit extra but i
got this for sure reason of i've always
loved this type of sports bracelet and
it's hardy i beat my watches i don't
like wearing them and being prissy about
them they get scratched they get
scratched that's that just adds to their
patina you can see how scratched that
bracelet is i'm really bad with this but
uh i love wearing it
and it's probably the
the heaviest
that i own
final watch i'm going to talk about is
the iwc portugieser this is the watch
that i wore to my first oscars with a
beautiful
ralph lauren custom tuxedo felt
a million bucks and this watch was my
companion for that night it's one of the
larger watches that i have actually
probably the largest it's beautiful
classic design iwc do great watches and
and not crazy crazily sort of out of
reach it has a
seven-day reserve which you can sort of
see there so moving a little bit when
you wind it obviously with all automatic
watches you can do a sort of a manual
wind has a huge window in the back so
you get to see the inner workings it's
one of the brands that have been around
for the longest time so you know you're
getting the value and the historic
value i suppose it watches and it's all
about
pomp and and history uh when it comes to
luxury brands and how long they've been
around how long they've been innovating
but iwc is definitely one of the uh
the brands that uh are consistent
i've been telling myself when i told my
wife that i won't
but
there's been a couple
um that have sort of cropped up i would
not say no
i think
uh to indulge in
your
yearnings and and needs for
luxury once in a while you should submit
to them if it makes sense and you're
financially safe watches are an absolute
luxury you do not need them
if you're in a in a sensible place to be
able to afford them why not luxuriate in
them alright guys that's it for talking
through all of my watch collection
amazing spending time with you all and
hopefully it inspires you to
create collect and garner more special
pieces in your own collection